CARTER MORGAN: It's time to
look at the Kubernetes API
and how it makes modeling the
application lifecycle easier.
With a whole universe
of things to learn,
it's important to start
with the essentials.
Let's go over the
concepts that make
Kubernetes usable, scalable,
and just downright awesome.
Are you ready?
Kaslin, when it comes to what
scalable applications need,
we've talked about
containers and nodes,
but that's just the
tip of the iceberg.
There's plenty more we need in
order to run a full scalable
application.
KASLIN FIELDS:
Exactly, and that's
where the Kubernetes
API comes in.
It offers some really
convenient primitives
that make managing cloud native
applications a lot easier.
We've already talked
about a few API objects,
like pods and nodes, but there's
also services, deployments,
secrets, and many more.
CARTER MORGAN: That's a lot.
Why don't we start simple and
use an example application?
We said that containers are the
first step to using Kubernetes,
so let's start
with this container
I built to run my Hello app.
This app is really simple.
It just returns "Hello"
whenever I ping it
on its local IP in port 8080.
So what next?
KASLIN FIELDS: Well, the
first thing we have to do
is to create some
machines, or nodes,
to run your application on.
CARTER MORGAN: Got you.
OK, I'll use Google Kubernetes
Engine to quickly get started.
I can just use the
gcloud command line tool
to provision a
Kubernetes cluster.
After a few minutes,
we'll have a cluster
that's all ready to go, and by
default comes with three nodes.
This is a great starting
point, but now we
need to actually run my app.
So how do we do that?
KASLIN FIELDS: Since we're
using the command line,
we can use a handy tool called
kubectl to help interact
with the Kubernetes API.
Don't worry, we'll go into
kubectl in more detail later.
But we're keeping
it simple, remember?
CARTER MORGAN: But what
about all these other tools
I've heard of, kubecontrol,
kubecuddle, kube-ectl?
KASLIN FIELDS: There are
a lot of different ways
to pronounce the
name of this tool,
so whatever works for you.
Anyway, this command
is actually going
to create a Kubernetes API
object called a deployment.
CARTER MORGAN: A deployment
is an abstraction
that manages the life
cycle of an application.
I can set the desired
number of app instances
for the deployment to
manage, and then it
will make sure the correct
number of instances,
or replicas, are running.
KASLIN FIELDS: Exactly.
So if we increase the number
of replicas that we want,
the deployment will see
that there's currently not
enough replicas and
spin up another one.
CARTER MORGAN: That even
works when a node crashes.
If the node goes down,
the current state
is once again different
from the desired state,
and Kubernetes will schedule
another replica for us.
Awesome.
Now I know my app is
running on these nodes.
How do I access it?
KASLIN FIELDS: For that, we'll
have to create a service.
This creates an
endpoint that we can
use to access the
running app instances.
In this case, we have
multiple app instances.
So this service will load
balance incoming requests
between the two running pods.
CARTER MORGAN: That's right.
For any container
inside of the cluster,
they can connect to my service
using the service's name.
Either way, the
service keeps track
of wherever the pod is running.
KASLIN FIELDS: That's
another example
of how Kubernetes
removes the need
to manually keep track of where
your containers are running.
Even if a pod were to go down,
once a new one comes back
online, the service
will automatically
update its list of endpoints
to target the new pod.
CARTER MORGAN: So Kubernetes
objects, like deployments
and services,
automatically ensure
that we have the right number
of app instances running
through pods, and that
we can always reach them.
This seems like it would allow
for some really cool features.
KASLIN FIELDS: Yes.
Features that used to
have to be manually coded
just become afterthoughts
when using Kubernetes.
For example, deployments make
things like rolling updates
really simple.
CARTER MORGAN:
Whoa, you're saying
that we can edit the
deployment and watch
the version of the
applications gradually change?
So let's say we
have three replicas,
and I want to put out a new
version of my application
that returns "Bye"
instead of "Hello."
You're saying I can update
my application container,
watch as the new version
is gradually rolled out,
and the deployment will bring
up new application instances
and start rerouting
traffic to them?
Then once the desired number
of new instances are online,
the old application
instances are taken offline?
This would mean this
approach has zero downtime,
since Kubernetes is
incrementally updating old pod
instances with new ones.
KASLIN FIELDS: Exactly right.
And a feature like
that, plus the ability
to quickly roll
back if necessary,
and keeping track of deployment
histories and more, all of that
is just built into Kubernetes.
That's a large part of what
makes it such a great tool
to build other systems and
applications on top of.
CARTER MORGAN: The
Kubernetes API really
does make it easy to manage
the application lifecycle.
The basic primitives--
podds, service, deployments,
plus a few more we'll
talk about soon--
allow sysadmins and
developers to focus on the app
without having to worry
about managing it at scale.
But one thing I noticed is that
we used an imperative approach.
We made manual commands,
instead of using
a declarative
approach, which is one
of the big appeals
of Kubernetes.
KASLIN FIELDS: Great catch.
Next episode, let's
dig into that.
We'll use Kubernetes the way
it was intended to be used,
by updating config files.
Starting with an
example monolith,
we'll break it up into
a microservices style
architecture.
This will also
let introduce some
of the other core primitives
that we didn't talk about,
like labels and secrets.
CARTER MORGAN: We're
going to pair code
up a microservice
version of this?
Hm.
OK, stay tuned, everybody.
Next time, we'll be exploring
building a basic Kubernetes
app from scratch.
In the meantime, if you
want to get hands-on,
check out the link
in the description.
And if you enjoyed the
episode, subscribe for more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]